je trouve ça d'abord pitoyable mais en
même temps je ne suis pas surpris
monsieur benalla et l'entourage général
ne cesse de mentir de cacher la vérité
il faut que ce soit la presse qui petit
à petit certes les éléments je pense que
nous ne sommes pas au bout du système
est qu'il y aura sans doute encore
d'autres révélations
en tous les cas ce qui apparaît sous
réserve que tout cela soit et vérifié
évidemment ils nous ont de l'apprendre
mais ce qui apparaît c'est que il est on
ne peut pas lui faire confiance à aucun
moment ce qui jette le doute évidemment
sur l'ensemble de ses déclarations et
sur l'ensemble de la situation
donc il ya un moment où vous êtes
peut-être falloir passer la vitesse
supérieure pour qu'on sache réellement
quelle est la situation que la nature de
ses liens
quel est son rôle actuel at il toujours
un rôle actuellement en tous les cas ce
qu'il dit lui-même montre à l'évidence
qu'il a toujours un rôle avec l'elysée
au sens large
je ne pourrais pas me permettre de dire
et qui en particulier la commission d
enquête parlementaire n'était elle pas
dans l'incapacité de trouver la vérité
lorsque l'on voit est bien la quantité
de contradictions voire de mensonges et
de parjure peut-être qu'il y a eu devant
la commission d'enquêté parlementaire
n'est pas un juge d'instruction
donc elle ne fonctionne que sur des
auditions et en fonction de ce qui est
dit en prêtant serment
mais oui bien sûr donc il a menti c'est
un parjure permanent donc évidemment
qu'on ne peut pas avoir confiance et que
le doute plus que le doute sauf que
notre mission s'est arrêté donc il en
revient maintenant à la justice de
saisir la justice et qu'elle justice
fasse son travail avec autant de
célérité qu'elle l'a fait dans les
époques récent qui les sénateurs doivent
donc saisir la justice sur tout ses
parjures à titre personnel je suis tout
à fait favorable oui